[Musique]
bienvenue aux porches et al thani moi
j'ai commencé par un bep
j'ai fait cette année d'école par
alternance mais moi ce qui me
caractérise c'est le terrain compte
donc j'étais arrivé à la réunion suite à
une mutation donc dans un groupe ii du
btp c'est en tant que directeur génér
partir en métropole puisque j'étais en
assimiler expats et sauf que moi ma vie
était ici mes enfants étaient ici donc
j'ai voulu rester à la réunion
ça a été très compliqué au début
puisqu'il n'y a aucune aucune banque qui
suivent
voilà le fait d'être demandeur d'emploi
ça me permet d'avoir une aide pendant
deux ans ce qui permet de ne pas tirer
de ces rames entreprises pendant des
années ce qui est juste considérables
sans cette aide s'est clairement
impossible
une des premières portes qui s'est
ouverte cette initiative entreprendre
donc la réunion donc j'ai décroché un
crédit de 20 mille euros
ce qui m'a permis de me lancer donc ici
nous avons l'atelier et petit à petit on
a commencé à embaucher on a fait débat
des cloisons on a fait des dessins voilà
on a fait des bureaux donc dans mon
bureau ce qu'on peut voir ces choses sur
l'important pour moi c'est la famille
notamment donc ça fait partie de des
valeurs fortes du départ de la création
de l'entreprise l'equilibre perso pro
dans l'entreprise est hyper important
les gens ils ont pas vraiment d'horaires
l'aménagement du temps est vraiment
quelque chose de présents dans
l'entreprise
le télétravail est aussi présent qui me
tenait à coeur en fête c'est d'avoir des
valeurs humaines dans l'entreprise que
j'ai pas forcément connu ailleurs je
voulais que mes salariés s'approprient
cette entreprise un management qu'on
appelle entre guillemets à l'horizontale
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas des chefs de
chef de chef de chef
non ici on est tous au même niveau tout
le foot ou 9,24 propres nets ont fait du
bon boulot tout le temps oui j'ai
félicité patrick pasquier du bon boulot
et quand c'est bien faut savoir le dire
s'est développée au mois de mars très
fortement alors que tout le monde me
sens y est presque
et nous on a embauché on a embauché des
gens qui étaient au chômage au début de
l'année ont été très peu nombreux ont
été 2 donc une grosse croissance sur
l'année
on essaie de faire en sorte que les
salariés et du bon matériel pour
travailler c'est hyper important lors on
a aussi un partage des richesses dans
l'entreprise
tout le monde gagne c'est pas que pour
le directeur on a régulièrement des
primes qui sont données à nos salariés
parce que les chantiers se sont bien
passées et donc voilà qui sait écouter
inspire confiance
y a pas de mal à changer d'avis pourvu
que cette fois du bon sens
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue chez beethoven à
saint-paul m'a connu mon compagnon l'a
donc mon mari depuis 20 ans cette année
une à cinq enfants ont construit notre
entreprise ensemble ont été sérieuses
ensuite mal à arrêter quatre métiers
différents informations c'est sûr tu as
il était demandeur d'emploi allait aller
vers la chambre des métiers maaf
accompagnement apparaissait donc mais
comptable le département aussi mahut a
attaqué sur certaines portes et
franchement elle a été ouverte
les banques aussi la suivante quand on
commence une autre pause avec 500 euros
ont fini l'année avec trois quatre
camions en oeuvre par les parties quoi
me dit on a pu n'a pu rien pokal à eau
alors mon mari c'est une entreprise
familiale qui sera amené à se développer
par la suite alors beethoven est
spécialisée dans le béton comme nous
fait du sol décoratifs industriels ainsi
que pour les particuliers dû balayer
désactiver autres nous fait aussi du
béton drainant sémaphore mieux de béton
à moi c'est à l'évacuation plus rapide
de l'eau j'aimerais arriver à vendre mon
produit à moi en tant que mobilier
urbain arrivé à remplacer nous indigner
à béton fait mais on commence en tant
que locataire innova dieu merci ne finit
en tant que prestataire attitré des tpc
ma petitesse et mopar couramment à les
personnels mais il n'y aura pas tout
mais au fond c'est niet franchement cinq
siècles mais fier de moi
pas mal de prestations aa m en 9 s btp
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous les a4 quatre
employés dans mon entreprise dont
moi-même et l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
12 avant février 2021 mois et la suter à
tous les jours mais elle a au bureau est
la peau mes enfants est là pour mon mari
mais là pour moi même déjà
financièrement mon enveloppe à moi les
geste pas possible à suivre ben soit
c'est le petit bonheur la chance
ça c'est le département ça c'est les
banques n'est pas fait pour moi
les périodes il préfère voir un jeune
notre travail est une famille accompagné
dans la vie de tous les jours
suis sentie si le maintien ça m'a même
volé minogue en a eu dans la boue devant
la boutique tout simplement aussi attend
jamais à menton mais du ciel il tombera
pas mon enfant
donc en clair soleil palmata peau et
travail n'aura jamais rien
la finale a eu lieu au palais de la
source
c'est là que david le gall de
l'entreprise alten y gagne dans la
catégorie création d'emplois
[Musique]
je